i want to tell you mike um
i watched that last night and just
watching it again
i won't be able to watch it again
without breaking down
i just won't it was it was difficult to
watch it last night and it was in
it was difficult just now watching that
james white everybody when everybody
heard
about the tragedy and that's really what
it was
with his parents losing his father
everybody in the nfl
spoke up about james white you could
just tell what kind of man he is
and how authentic he is he is just a
real person that's one two
dads out there do you hear what he just
said
that my father my father was there for
me
my father showed up two my father pushed
me
that's motivation three my father told
me things
that i didn't necessarily wanted to hear
but
that i needed to hear there was so much
mike
there was just so much in that clip his
emotion
his wife is pregnant right now going
through so many things
so many family things going through his
mind football uh
understandably not number one on his
priority list
but just hearing about the relationship
that he had with his father
and then just losing that relationship
suddenly uh is heartbreaking
and and it's instructive to uh all
fathers out there
yeah it was inspiring that that was
similar to my
my take away from it or my reaction to
hearing it because
you know they're they're at random times
and my kids will look at me funny when i
ask them
but i'll just ask them i'll be like yo
am i good dad
you know i want to be like of course
yeah why would you why would you ask
that
and you know like we don't know when
it's our time
but whenever i go like all i want
my only my only prayer is that
my kids remember me that fondly
that my kids appreciate me
know that i did the best that i could
know that i tried to give them every
opportunity every advantage
but but more than anything
know that i was that i i wanted a
relationship
and i worked hard at the relationship
and then i loved them and that i
i gave them attention and affection um
and that they knew that they're the most
important thing to me you know like i
just want my kids to look
back on their time with me however long
we have
and reflect on it fondly um
that's it you know like that's that's
that's my
number one job is as savannah mason
and maya's dad um
you know because and you and i have
talked about this
you know we are directly responsible as
fathers for
you know how our sons
view value and treat women
yes how that's right our daughters
view value and treat themselves
as well as how they demand or expect to
be treated by
men uh you know and as the case may be
but
both of us you know are believers uh we
are responsible for
how our children view their relationship
with god as father
and so um you know i
they're that's the main thing that i try
to just kind of
make sure is that is that my kids just
know how much i love them
and know how much how hard i am trying
and and appreciate it because i
do i know like there are days especially
the older they get i know you see this
too man it's like
they just at that time even even in the
pandemic we were able to spend this time
with them you're literally you're
literally able to
watch them rapidly grow before your eyes
yes and when you're watching them grow
you're like
man i'm never getting this back like i'm
never getting this back
like i'm never getting these little kids
back so you get one shot at this thing
you get one shot you know and if you
mess it up
you know and we're gonna make mistakes
as parents but that's right that's it
yeah yeah
you can't you can't we have we have
right we have yeah
but but but hopefully you get them to
adulthood with as few scars as possible
both
both emotional and physical right but
you don't get you don't get a second
chance at this thing you know
you know it it's uh it's interesting
mike uh just a couple a couple quick
things on this one
uh you probably went through this uh
when your kids are small
i'm someone really young you know like
three months old four months old
and you can say things around the three
or four month old
and you don't have to worry about it
coming back to you because they couldn't
talk right
so yeah i remember saying to my wife
uh when our oldest started to talk i
said we're on the record now
we're on the record everything
everything that we're saying now listen
don't say anything that you don't want
to hear coming back don't say anything
about your mama
because it might it might get back to
her through these uh
through these young lips you know but
in all seriousness we're on the record
whether we realize it or not it's not
just what we say it's just our actions
it's like absolutely you ever do this
your kids mention things to you
hey hey dad remember that time we went
here and you said this and i'm thinking
what did i say what did i do and they
tell me they wind up telling me a story
and it's a pretty funny story
but they remember so many things so many
things
really have an impact on them and i was
watching that you know to bring it back
to james white
i was watching that last night with a
guy that you know very well and have a
lot of respect for
former patriot ted johnson so ted
johnson is watching that
and he started to get a little choked up
because he could relate to it
he was saying i remember he said my dad
used to call me even when i was in the
pros my dad used to call me before
every game and say the same thing
and it was just it wasn't like it was
anything profound but that was part of
our routine that was that was a part of
our relationship that i really look
forward to it
and what his father used to say to him
i'll tell you what it was his father
used to say to him
make sure you look you look in the
interception before you bring it into
you
because you don't he's a linebacker make
sure you look at that interception
before you bring it in
he had one career interception
before every game yeah and that's what
was coming
yeah i'd say who was it against he said
stan humphreys tip ball
i got it you know but then his dad would
say well look you know you didn't get
that interception because nobody throws
to your zone you know inside linebacker
but it was just
it was part of the thing and and i think
that's what
it doesn't always have to be that that
that big thing
and i would say this to dads in
particular all parents but dads in
particular
those who are looking for a relationship
with their kids if you don't have that
relationship it's not always
hey i'm going to buy him this i'm going
to take him here we're going to go on
vacation i am
it's time it's just time it's just it's
attention just bro i got four i got it
four years being there and being present
i got four years left with some i got
four years left with savannah
i got four years left before i i send
her
you know out in the world this is like
it's just like it's a scary thought
it is a scary thought to realize just
how how quickly
um you know the time passes but man you
know like it's good to always talk to
you about this man nobody i respect for
you know uh as a father um
and you're right on the record is right
man i mean i try i try to watch it you
know
losing my temper or or or or just
because because that
bruh and this is i promise you sorry
courtney this is the last thing i'll say
it is generational it is generate these
are generational seeds that we're sowing
because how you raise robinson and
beckham and
even how i raised savannah mason and
maya
that's that reverberates for generations
to come like that's
the husbands and wives they grew up
being that's the
parents they grew up being so their
children's children's children
ex you know experience the benefits or
the the ramifications of our decisions
as parents right now it's an awesome
responsibility we could spend all show
talking about it
but uh but we can't but okay one more
thing one more thing okay okay
all right i promise i'm not gonna say no
this is just you you let you let this
you
this you just let the record show
courtney michael stop you from going to
break that's it this is you go ahead
one more thing i'm always amazed and i
think it you know you talk about
generational you're talking about
you're talking about you passing it on
to your to your son and your daughters
and and they're passing on
family generation i think it might be of
a certain generation too because i hear
i hear some brothers and sisters uh a
little bit older than i am
say you know i never heard my father say
that he loved me oh i never heard my mom
just say just just say i knew she loved
me
by her actions but i never heard her say
it and
that's always been amazing to me and so
i can i can tell you and not that i'm
you know some
amazing dad but that is one thing that i
just
i never want that to be said i'll say it
20 times a day i'll say it 25 times a
day
and i will encourage you like if you if
you're in that position
you're watching two dudes on zoom and
you're in that position
just try it just say it it's easy enough
to say and it's
it's powerful hi i'm mike tarico and
thanks for watching
make sure to hit subscribe for the
latest news and highlights
from nbc sports